new in theaters this weekend miss Bala
this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
you gotta learn how to use one of these
a viola bullet well I said it was
everything Jane the Virgin kicking butt
okay action thriller miss Bala hits the
big screen this weekend
starring Gina Rodriguez best known as
the lead from the CW comedy-drama Jane
the virgin miss Bala follows the story
of an la-based makeup artist who gets
caught between the DEA and a Tijuana
drug cartel after her best friend Zuzu
is kidnapped building that you blew up
the DEA safe house you know how long you
go away for unless you help us you know
Esparza turns out makeup skills do
translate to undercover drug smuggling
informants skills this movies for you if
you like international cartel action
movies you're curious about Gina
Rodriguez exploring the action genre or
you want to be Miss Bala shot kala
20-inch blades on the Impala never big
is hard but it wasn't easy
that is your weekend ticket check back
next week to find out exactly what men1
Pizza episode over
[Music]